a block is initially at position x
equals zero and in contact with an
uncompressed spring of negligible mass
the block is pushed back along a
frictionless surface from position x
equals zero to x equals negative d as
shown above compressing the spring by an
amount delta x equals d
so the block starts here
and it's just in contact with the spring
so it's initially the spring is
uncompressed and it's just touching the
block and then we start to compress the
spring by pushing the block to the left
and we compress it by an amount d they
tell us that right there delta x is
equal to d so we compress
we move this block back over to the left
by d and that compresses the spring by d
the block is then released at x equals
zero the block enters a rough part of
the track and eventually comes to rest
at position x equals 3d so when we
compress the spring we're actually doing
work to compress the spring and so that
work that energy from that or the the
the work we're doing gets stored as
potential energy in the spring block
system and then when we let go that
potential energy is going to be
converted to kinetic energy and that
block is going to be accelerated all the
way until we get back to x equals zero
then the spring is back to uncompressed
so it's not going to keep pushing on the
block after that point and then the
block is going to have this kinetic
energy and if there was no friction in
this gray part here would just keep on
going forever and if there's no air
resistance and we're assuming no air
resistance for this for this
problem but since there is friction it's
just going to decelerate it at a
constant rate you're going to have a
constant force of friction being applied
to this block
so let's see they say they tell us and
it's going to come to rest at x equals
3d the coefficient of kinetic friction
between the block and the rough track is
mu
all right on the axis below sketch and
label graphs of the following two
quantities as a function of the position
of the block between x equals negative d
and x equals 3d you do not need to
calculate values for the vertical axis
but the same vertical scale should be
used for both quantities so they have
the kinetic energy of the block and the
potential energy of the block spring
system so let's first focus on the
potential energy u because when we start
the first part of this when we're
compressing the spring that's when we're
starting to put potential energy into
this spring block system and so you have
to think about what is the potential
energy of a compressed spring
well the potential energy
the potential energy is equal to
one-half
times the spring constant times how much
you compress the string the spring
squared so if we want to say delta x is
how much you compress the spring
that squared now if what i just wrote is
completely unfamiliar to you i encourage
you to watch the videos on khan academy
and the potential energy of a compressed
spring or the work necessary to compress
a spring because the work necessary to
compress the spring that's going to be
the potential energy that you're
essentially putting in to that system
and so for this as we compress the
spring to d you are you're going to end
up with a potential energy of one-half
times the spring constant
times our change in x is d
our change in x is d times d
times d
the squared so let's plot that on this
right over here so right whoops
right when we are
at
x equals zero there's no potential
energy in our system but then we start
to compress it and when we get to x
equals d we're gonna have a potential
energy of one half times the spring
constant times d squared so let's just
say this right over here
let's say that
over there actually let me do a
see that one is actually i'll do it over
here so it'll be useful for me later on
so let's say that this right over here
is one half times our spring constant
times d squared so this is what our
potential energy is going to be like
once we've compressed the spring by d
and it's not going to be a linear
relationship remember the potential
energy
potential energy is equal to one-half
times the spring constant
times the spring constant times how much
you've compressed the spring squared
so the potential energy increases as a
square of how much we compress the
spring so when we've compressed the
spring half as much you're going to have
one-fourth the potential energy so it's
going to look like this it's going to be
you could view it as the left side of a
parabola
so it's going to
going to look something
something like this
so that's the potential energy
now when you're in this point when the
the thing is fully compressed and then
you let go
what happens
well that potential energy is turned
into kinetic energy so as the spring as
the spring accelerates the block you're
going to go down this potential energy
curve as you go to the right but then it
gets converted to kinetic energy so the
potential energy plus the kinetic energy
needs to be constant at least over this
period from x equals negative d to x
equals zero so the kinetic energy starts
off
at zero it's stationary but then it
starts the block starts getting
accelerated it starts getting
accelerated and the sum
the sum of these two things
needs to be equal to one half times our
spring constant times d squared and so
you could see if you if you were to add
these two curves at any position you are
going their sum is going to sum up to
this value and so right when you get
back to x equals zero all of that
potential energy has been converted into
kinetic energy and then that kinetic
energy
we would stay at that high kinetic
energy if there was no friction or no
air resistance but we know that the
block comes to a rest at x is equal to
3d so all the kinetic energy is gone at
that point and you might say well what's
that getting converted into well it's
getting converted into into heat due to
the friction so that's where you know
energy cannot be can not be created out
of thin air or lost into thin air it's
converted from one form to another and
so the question is what type of a curve
is this do we just connect these with a
line or is it some type of a curve and
the key realization is is that you have
a constant force of friction the entire
time that the block is being slowed down
the coefficient of friction doesn't
change so the force of friction or the
mass of the block isn't changing so the
force of friction is going to be the
same and it's acting against the motion
of the block so you can you can view the
friction as essentially doing this
negative work and so it's sapping the
energy away if you think about it
relative to distance in a given amount
of distance it's sapping away the same
amount of energy it's doing that same
amount of negative work
and so this is going to decrease at a
linear rate
and so let me draw that
so it's going to be a
linear decrease
just like that and the key thing to
remind yourself is is this is a plot of
energy versus position not velocity
versus position or velocity versus time
or energy versus time time this is
energy versus position and that's what
gives us this linear relationship right
over here so
we have the kinetic energy k of the
block
that's what i did in magenta so this is
the kinetic energy
kinetic
kinetic energy
and in blue just to make sure i label it
right this is the potential energy
potential
energy